أريد أن أعرف أنهم لم يعد بإمكانهم استخدام
أموالنا مجانًا بعد الآن، حان الوقت
الآن، لذلك دعونا نغلقها غدًا
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
فلسطين، تعرف على كيفية القيام بذلك بالضبط
في هذا الفيديو ولكن أولاً أريدك أن
تعرف  أن نقل أموالنا من هذه
البنوك الكبيرة سيكون له
تأثير مقطعي ليس فقط على دولة الاحتلال،
وليس فقط على الفلسطينيين، ولكن الكثير
من هذه البنوك الكبيرة تستثمر في شركات
الوقود الأحفوري الضخمة
[الموسيقى]
التي تنقل الأموال إليها إلى الشركات
المحلية  الاتحادات الائتمانية الاتحادات الائتمانية المحلية
أينما كنت، لا يهم
أي منها تجد ما يتوافق مع
قيمك. الاتحادات الائتمانية المحلية هي
[موسيقى]
غير ربحية
أوه [
موسيقى] هو هو هو هيه هيه هيه
هيه
[موسيقى]